bonsoir raphaël pennes de vacances de
pâques hors des frontières pour les
belges effectivement en fait la belgique
a décidé de maintenir cette interdiction
des voyages non essentiels pour les
belges qui souhaitent sortir du
territoire mais également pour les
voyageurs étrangers qu'ils
souhaiteraient se rendre en belgique et
ce jusqu'au 18 avril au moins mais il ya
tout de même des perspectives qui ont
été donnés à la population notamment
pour les activités en plein air en ce
qui concerne par exemple les sports en
extérieur ou les événements culturels de
50 personnes maximum pourront reprendre
à partir du mois d'avril
et puis la date du 1er mai qui a été
également donné pour la réouverture des
bars des restaurants et également des
cinémas des salles de spectacles de
concerts qui vont pouvoir et ouvrir
normalement d'ici le 1er mai une autre
bouffée d'oxygène c'est celle que vous
faire profiter les belges avec la bulle
social extérieur qui va être étendu dès
ce lundi 2 4 à 10 personnes
donc on pourra se rasseoir assemblée où
jusqu'à 10 personnes en extérieur et
puis dernière chose les étudiants ont
supérieurs pourraient assister une fois
par semaine pour en présentiel
alors bien sûr le gouvernement l'a
rappelé toutes ces mesures
et bien cet assouplissement des mesures
cela dépend de l'évolution de la
pandémie en belgique merci beaucoup
raphaël blandamour journaliste en direct
de bruxelles